I know you do a lot of the mill thing
what is the age range on that
um and what is the age range on that on
that Mill thing
so I'm not
um are you an age demon or is it this
matter is it just about that I think
it's going to be like I mean I think
most people probably can assume but like
you know some people just don't really
get it like
I'm not loyal to only older women no
that's not yeah people people do make
that assumption is there a video
that dropped of me walking in Buffalo
New York with this girl who was just
clearly not a MILF whole lands and it
got like six million views and all the
comments were just oh my God bro that's
not a MILF what is going on I was like
dude like
I mean yeah MILFs are dope but I'm not
I'm not it's like a solar eclipse or
something I'm not discriminating man